this gve W that is a representation of a
graph we I'm not a gra well you are I
mean if the graph given to us by the
teacher model is good enough and that's
what we are
[Music]
showing record a yeah yeah sure sure
sure sure this is an amplifier I'll just
restart again Shia solving the problem
of pre-layout Designing and uh we start
with a schematic the designer a
schematic and some specifications
associated with it like let's say this
is an amplifier so gain has to be higher
than this value the unity gain bandwidth
must be greater than this and all of
those specifications but at the same
time make sure that the objective
function is also kind of minimized or
maximized depending upon what the
objective is so how do you solve this
problem so we have divided this whole
thing into three stages first is called
as graph of circuits second is the graph
surrogate model third is the constraint
optimization now let me just go through
the whole pseudo code of it so first
step is learning a graph second is is is
doing a label propagation on the
unlabeled instances third is generating
a surrogate model and fourth is the
constraint optimization let's go on to
the first step so the general General
literature around this particular work
has mean is that when you have this
particular schematic consider this whole
thing as a graph so what you do is make
multiple such graphs so it becomes a
graph regression problem the label will
be gain ugb gain margin phase margin
corresponding to each of the Circ inst
question about the creation of the graph
what are the nodes and what are the
edges according to the
each node is going to be the circuit
component resistance capacitance
transistors all of those things but as I
mentioned you have to generate multiple
such graphs and it is always going to be
a supervised setting problem so
obviously it is going to be
computationally very expensive
generating those labels is also going to
be very cumbersome task right so what we
are saying is reformulate this whole
thing into a node regression problem and
a semi supervised learning framework how
do you do that instead of taking this
whole thing as one graph consider this
thing as a whole feature Vector right so
these are multiple such feature vectors
and generate labels only corresponding
to few samples keep most of them as
unlabeled now how do you generate a
graph out of it this gve W that is a
representation of a graph this W
corresponds to the weighted adjacency
how do you get that by solving this
optimization formulation it has three
steps first is call as a directional
energy so what it says is the circuit
instances where the difference between
features is pretty less make sure that
they are connected with very high
weights right so that is the first term
second is the sparcity term you don't
want the graph to be very dense or fully
connected so you are incorporating a
sparcity term and the third one is the
regularizer just to make sure that your
weights does not go down to zero so from
here you end up with a graph where you
have some samples which are labeled most
of them are going to be unbled second
part so this uh completes our first task
yes yes yes what's here node is going to
be a whole circuit oh whole circuit yes
yes yes this will have this feature
vectors like maybe design all the design
parameters like vdd the width of your
transistor length of the transistor all
all of those things that will contribute
to the one feature Vector of a node and
then the xes are what exactly feature
vectors that is a design Matrix so as I
mentioned like let's say this is a
circuit which you have in hand so the
bdd so it can go to 1 2 1.5 2.5 all
these real values are going to be vdd so
these will contribute to different
instances similarly for W1 it will be
maybe 100 microm or 200 microm something
like that so that will be another row so
something like that so a stack of all
the yes yes yes but the so the I and the
J are going to be different
instantiations of x i and XJ so in that
way so it is going to be o n Square
times so because each one will be
Computing with all the uh different uh
uh features available in within that
particular stack yeah right now why do
you need a surrogate model so the
problem with Genera labels here is now
let's say you take a feature Vector this
feature Vector is your one circuit you
pass it through your simulator as the
circuit size increases the chances of
generating one particular label may go
up to uh it take time up to maybe 30
minutes or more than that as a circuit
sign increases it can go up to hours so
you can understand if I just want to
generate a label data set for thousand
like some volag yeah yeah yeah gain ugb
gain margin so all of these are labels
so it's a multi- label scenario so
generate think just a label data set of
thousand samples will take maybe weeks
right so we don't want to do that so we
have to come up with a way which kind of
approximates the working of a spice
simulator and that is done by this graph
surrogate model so now what you do is
you take this graph you take this graph
with few labeled and most of them
unlabeled pass pass it through a GNN GNN
will train only on the labeled sample
say and do the label prediction
corresponding to the unlabeled ones so
this is how you come up to the third
step second and third this Yu is the
label prediction so which you can see
over here and once you have done that
you have a gcx GNN which is your graph
surrogate model which which is going to
uh you know serve the purpose of your
spy simulator now the fourth and the
final step take this surrogate model
incorporate it with some uh constant
optimization formulation like Esco and
ASO and get the most optimal design
parameters so here for constant
optimization we are proposing two
algorithms first is the esaso which is
also called as static optimization
framework and second is the ASO which is
the dynamic learning framework so let's
me first explain what is esas so you can
see this one this is the stack which is
the first step here right generate a
graph by using that particular
formulation next train a GNN on it get
labels corresponding to all the samples
this is the step now let's say
originally your graph was th000 notes
now You observe that out of the Thousand
noes there are just 20 noes which are
satisfying all those constraints but can
you say that they are going to be the
most optimal ones no right so what you
do is take these 20 nodes and comput
Bounds on the features of those
particular nodes pass it to the D
algorithm that D algorithm will minimize
your objective function and give you one
or maybe some multiple Solutions based
on the convexity of your objective
function right but now these particular
uh new Solutions which you have will not
have the labels so how so it again
becomes this particular problem so what
you do you learn a graph and uh do the
label prediction and you will most
assured get these solutions that these
optimal design parameters will have the
labels which have satisfied all those
constraint and as as the objective
function is minimized but what is the
problem why why why do we not stop at
this particular place is the reason is
as the specification size increases we
have observed that the chances of
getting those particular nodes might end
up to zero right so initially I
mentioned that there might be 20 nodes
but what if there the number boost down
to zero right so in that case we need
some other alternative and that is the
dynamic learning framework so what do we
do here is we start with all the label
samples but very few label samples just
20 or 50 right you rerank those samples
based on what criteria based on a
criteria of the probability of the
satisfying constraints the samples which
does that should be placed at the
highest of the stack right so take just
few samples out of it now pass it
through the D algorithm get new feature
vectors but you don't have the label for
it it again becomes this particular
problem get the labels using the GNN so
now you have this particular problem
where the stack is completely labeled of
maybe just 50 samples again rerank it
again pass it to the DL keep doing it
until you have started from a space
which was uniformly sampled across the D
Dimension space but now you're
converging towards a space which are
which will most probably give you uh the
most optimal design parameters put the
iteration budget or maybe make sure uh
that the difference between the loss
functions or the objective function is
whatever that can be the iteration
budget for it and uh at the end of it
you're going to get the design
parameters which have satisfied all the
specifications at the same time your
objective function is also minimized
this is the whole work very cool yeah
thank you thank you so may I just uh try
to say this again like based on my
understanding so you may have a certain
let's say a certain number of circuit
instance and you don't know whether it
satified this proper or not but you can
construct some features right like some
design parameters and use this design
parameters to solve this problem to
Connected all of the circuit instances
into a big graph kind of each node
correspond to one circuit incidence got
it right and you also have uh the node
features correspond to this features and
also node label some only a very few
number of circuit has a labels here and
then you view use gen at the kind of
semister wide learning way right to
train on those labels right okay and
then you also get some labels for maybe
those
other okay and uh and then yeah I I lost
the rest of St yeah so I keep this
the question is do you do you just
assume you have some labeled ones or are
you also depending on the graph deciding
which ones are the most optimal to label
uh no no no the labeling is done in a
random way because obviously we don't
know where the optimal solution will lie
but if you can you do the graph without
the labels yeah yeah yeah then
technically you could decide okay a very
Central node is the one that I should
get my label for um maybe that can be
another question can we optimally decide
which labels we should have for
Max exactly right okay but you just
assume you have some kind of random
labels available okay and then you you
go on and you you have two different
methods but in in one essentially you
say let's train a ranker on these things
and whenever we run out of labeled
samples we just kind of make some more
and use the GNN to label those and then
we rerank again and so we try to go up
up
up so I I I have a question here so here
you will have have some labels some
label y for let's say those
unlabeled and then I lost the rest of
thing like
how yeah yes yes yes yes sir okay so uh
the thing which you're saying we have
reached here cor so now what I was
saying is let's say you had a graph of
th000 notes okay now you generate uh now
You observe that there are only 20 notes
which is satisfying all your constraints
so here I have a question so my so for
all the constraints here each one of it
could be a a correspond to one label
here right so one type of label yes okay
you are doing something like a
regression task kind of and there this
could be multi-dimension regression
right right okay right I see I see okay
and maybe a part of them certify this
and then you will throw them into the
simulator to together the ground TR read
out is this no no no no no no no because
again even if they are 20 they still
much right you don't want that time to
be wasted as
so take those 20 run an put an input
bound on those on the feature side right
and run it run a d algorithm on it so
what the D algorithm is going to do is
it is going to minimize your objective
function or let's say generic term
should be optimize your objective
function right and generate one or many
new Solutions based on the convexity of
your objective function but those
Solutions will not have labels correct
how do you get the labels so this
problem again becomes something like
this where you have some labels most of
them un
so but you have already trained your GNN
so that grate model will be used to put
the labels corresponding to the new
solution so so say how you get this new
solution like a kind of here solution I
guess you mean a design of a type of
design the labels the labels like the
game uh ugb those are my uh uh Solutions
so so basically GN output will be a
bench of like a labels or you call
solution suppose 20 of them satify the
hard constraint there and then you are
saying you want to run some like a the
algorithms right what is theth
differential Evolution algorithm so
there evolutionary algorithm in that's a
euristic one right so because you don't
know the form of your objective function
right so you cannot decide on previously
that whether it is going to be conx or
not so all your kkd conditions and all
of those things they may or may not work
there right so you want to have a
euristic algorithm which will satisfy
that that is much faster than a
simulator know like but a fistic or
traditionalistic algorithm right okay
run on the on those and then you will
select the best one then you will get
the new ones correct that solution will
one why this is a new one see so here
where I have 20 different circuit instan
right and the g output tells us the they
satify this hard constraints right and
then you will use a cisti which I know
is much faster but maybe slower than GM
but faster than simulator run on those
maybe get some like some objective or
some objective value for this circuit
and then why you say there's a new
design or new because those samples were
not previously available within my uh
graph right because I have what how you
for over them see the thing is because
we have used different algorithms like
Gat and Sage right so these are
inductive in nature so even though these
samples were not previously available in
my sample when I freeze my model
and do a label prediction corresponding
to a new graph it is most likely going
to give you the right Solutions because
I understand when you're saying that how
can we get those solutions that is going
so so my understanding is all so you you
actually have a series of graph circuits
like your series of circuits and all of
them are like uh previously already
designed and each of them correspond to
a node in the graph get it right so and
you select 20 of the nodes right Al you
don't know the ground TR but you have
theur to run some collect some
information is to generate the labels it
will generate the new
features what kind of new feature see
the thing is now let's say you have this
stack right okay these 20 nodes
corresponding to that you you you have
the labels as well correct because we
have done it a label prediction now
these let's say these are the nodes
which are satisfying all your
constraints right just focus on this
particular area the feature one okay
take the bounds on it understand where
the feature Vector is moving right okay
right within that particular bound run a
d algorithm oh so the D algorithm is not
try to infert the label of this 20 but
the more like you kind of it's its input
is
a some parameter space exactly okay and
J is try to give you uh okay A a more
sharper a sharper parameter space and
then you put that into the Cure okay I
see I I see the point and then you get
the new labels for the on okay okay I
thank you thank you very much I'm uh
reporting a bit from the conference is
it okay if I
record okay I have no clue what the core
problems in collaborative filtering are
okay it's basically typical way to solve
problem in recommend the system yeah so
in recommend system so what we do
basically is we're trying to find a
better loss in
recommendation okay and this loss can
achieve better generalization ability
the meaning of generalization ability
means uh for some external T data set
like when the testing and training are
different the distribution are
difference okay still perform not that
bad that generalization
well recommendation system so how could
we achieve this but what do you mean the
the test and training is different so
let's say Netflix right they recommend
movies to
users how what would generalization mean
yeah you will change something like the
taste of yourself okay you will divert
right based on this because we collect
the data like here and then we use data
this data to P the model and predict but
when we predict is future okay yeah and
your taste will change okay so this
basically is generalization of and the
difference between TR and okay and how
do you tackle that yeah solve this
problem basically recommendation is all
about banking banking Bank yeah one by
one what what are we truly interest in
which one is the first which one is the
second one yeah the order is all we care
about right and how can we do this we
use some laws m is a ranking okay we
have like Point wise law p wise law like
VPR or infy L recently very very popular
one in self-supervised learning or
contractive learning and for in for loss
actually what we have is we have
multiple netiv day here yeah and we we
have a unified predefined fisical B
which means we want J to be far away
from the positive okay this is only
constraint but this is not that good for
us because suppose some J I truly
dislike this J yeah then I want this J
to be far away from positive one but
suppose I might like this J although it
is netive right this one one might be
the positive one for me and we want this
J maybe closer so course for each J we
have this Delta here Oracle Delta I am
the god I find a fine brain banking
criteria for this well the J2 is more
likely to be the positive one J1 is far
away so J2 is the first one right yeah
so of course I have this fine gray
ranking criteria just like this for each
day we have the AR here so you know how
bad something is yeah how this how much
this a degree of this light here and we
call it harness whatever is some degree
of harness or degree of this light and
just based on this F gr ranking
Criterion we
can directly obtain this main part of
our new lws here and the only difference
between this new L AR influency of the
old influency loss this one is actually
here the Delta J yeah for each negative
J we have some degree of this one so you
just wait the negative sample by the
like the hardness in some way okay but
how to learn this we are not the God we
need to learn this you are not yeah I
made yes you made but still we need to
learn the
yeah how to here we use adverse training
to learn this Dela J so we maximum to
learn this Delta 3 and then minimum CA
to train the recommender and you may ask
me why you use adverse training why it
works right and we theoretically prove
that when we do this actually we are
equivalent to solving a distributional
robust problems yeah this distributional
robust problems is is designed for o out
of distribution problems yeah it has
already been proved that it can achieve
better generalization abilities okay so
basically we design a new law year very
similar to the old infuences influence
E1 slightly change and it can
theoretically prove that it will achieve
better generation gos very cool so help
me understand this so I'm maximize here
over a Delta where is the Delta here
that's okay so this is all the different
Deltas so I'm trying to get I'm trying
to see what is the worst case hardness
assignment
okay for here you right uh for the for
the I mean I prove this this is a Dr
right the definition of Dr and here here
we have a p Divergence between P0 and P
yeah P0 is train you can think like this
we have learned from g0 however we have
no idea about the testing which is p
yeah and D all assume one things like in
area like at when the p is not that far
from or in Era of ATA we can achieve not
bad
wor okay so you assume the worst case
that's still in in some in some region
and then you try to find the parameters
that are optimal for the worst case and
that guarantees that even if my tastes
change in the future it's still it's
still okay because even if my tastes
change in the worst possible way you're
still robust it's right well very
excellent very excellent you got 100%
thank you thanks I'm y nice yeah very
nice very nice what's your name my name
is
an
yes thank you so thank you so much I'm
doing a bit of reporting is it okay if I
record here sure okay okay could you let
me know a bit what what your research
now the pressure's on
huh yeah for sure no no worries are you
yourself familiar with knowledge
distillation or anything a little bit a
little bit how about Spectrum cluster a
little bit okay yeah so um what we're
trying to do here with knowledge
distillation is saying that something
that I've got some Future model that's
really large and I'm I just I need to
teach a smaller student model instead of
just trying to get the student student
model to learn exactly the outputs that
the heatr model gives I'm going to take
PA wi pairs of inputs and make sure that
the similarity between what the Su model
gives on those inputs is similar between
the student and the teacher model this
relation match okay I want similarity
between FSX I and fxj to be close to the
similarity that's between given by the
teacher model do you have a reasoning
why you would want that it seems like an
indirection unnecessary indirection why
wouldn't I just make match the fs XI to
Ft XI yeah well that's originally what
knowledge is still exactly yeah
empirically people have been seeing this
this work better sometimes the thing was
nobody had really given a theoretical
interpretation for why this was working
better kind of like how you're saying
why why should that work better and idea
for us comes down to essentially that
it's like a spectral cluster okay that
by looking at all these pairwise
similarities yeah as long as the teacher
model has learned a good enough graph
structure then the student model can
learn proberly from that graph structure
as it's well clustered of the idea here
so the main two takeaways being that
what is rkd really learning it's helping
us to learn clustering structure a
spectral clustering as you define things
in the right way which I can get to but
then the second one as I have that
clustering or that ability to capture
that clustering structure if I include
rkd in a semi-supervised learning
framework yeah then the amount of label
points I need is reduced because the
clustering structure in addition to the
the label supervision it can leverage
both of those to only see see less and
so the graph structure we're assuming
that the data that are sample has come
from is this population level and this
population level graph that's revealed
by the the teacher the teacher model so
these Edge weights between inputs are
revealed to us by the teacher model yes
what that means over here at this
population level induced graph if I
consider minimizers of this spectral
clustering eror yeah this is one of the
ways you can write spectral clustering
minimizers of that inside of a function
class such as like real networks so this
F LX MH is minimizers of this clustering
error inside of a function Class M so
flx that subset of the functions if this
graph right here is given to us by this
from the teacher model then this can be
Rewritten in this way that looks like
this spectral contrast okay kind of loss
you can def find a clustering error for
a set of functions like that that comes
down to how big the set of points that
are mismatched between the true
clustering and what F suggests the
clustering this yeah so with that
clustering error here and all these
definitions we can say if the graph
given to us by the teacher model is good
enough or clustered enough then the
clustering error on that set of
functions that minimizes this clustering
error is going to be small okay that's
the and the the L here is going to be
the networks we train for the
students um to match the T Tri gra or
this is saying at the PO population
level assuming that we'd have everything
but yes the the student model we learn
on the whole population we got to learn
on population would be this yes this
right here is then going from the
population to just a a sample from that
yeah you getting a rer complexity class
coming out there but so all this at the
end of the day tells us rkd is
essentially doing Special clustering
yeah okay this result over here then
says as I come into semi supervis
M leveraging rkd as as you know like a
regularization then as long as
everything's nice and clustered I can
get nice generalization guarantees and
Sample complexity guarantees saying that
I only need really a linear number of
labeled samples essentially in the best
case scenario I just need one label
Point per cluster yeah to have a good um
because you have the whole graph you
have the clicks or whatever given yeah
exactly it's it's like I'm adding in my
empirical risk yeah but this
minimization problem it's as if I'm I'm
taking F inside of these minimizers of
the spect uh the spectral clustering MH
then I don't need that many labeled
points so okay very cool what do you
then recommend let's say what kind of
problem would this now be best on from a
practical standpoint yeah albeit we
weren't doing it in a specific
application but where would seem to fit
for me would be I have a teacher model
that's just really large but I have a
lot of faith that that teacher model is
going to give me a good idea of
clustering structure that these outputs
are going to be well that it has really
learned dogs are different from cats and
that really on on that Global level in
that case I can use rkd to make sure my
student model matches those pairwise
similarities and that will help me to
learn the clustering structure that
would be given to you by the the teacher
the teure model do look like guess and
the similarity here is that any
similarity or does it need to fulfill
some stuff that's a good point I uh I
don't know of uh like necessarily
sufficient conditions on what that
similar similarity needs to be yeah
there's different ways of measuring
similarity in the in the literature but
we specifically used this just yeah
okay Square differences very cool well
thank you so much of very interesting
yeah appreciate it thanks keep good one
can I record while you do it yeah yeah
sure okay so the idea is that you know
that you have all this multiple methods
right the models which are trained for
classification purposes now if you try
to apply some kind of inversion attack
and you try to invert the gradients you
can reconstruct the signals back right
that's your original and that those are
your reconstructed images but
unfortunately what you see is when you
take a given two images original and
reconstructed you see that according to
this metric it is showing that that
these are the most similar ones like
because these metrics are often not
correlated so what you're saying is that
according to the human this was the most
similar to this so your privacy leakage
was happening but the metric suggested
that you know this metric was actually
that this were the most similar ones so
you picked up a wrong candidate so what
you're seeing is that again in this
setup that you have original image and
according to the human this information
Lage was happening more for this one but
the algorithm the the current Matrix
picked up this one likewise what you is
the same thing that means that the
current metrics if you would use they
often break so you need a universal
metric and that metric that coherently
and consistently Works across picking up
the right candidate samples which
actually leaks or doesn't leak the
information and that's what we also
showing here in a PSN or msse often two
metrics do not even correlate and
there's a huge mismatch like one metrix
says that you know that yes things are
similar one says no and therefore you
need one coh metric is what we propose
is that we get our data set annotated
according to the human Observer and once
you have annotated your data set that
did that some information leakage is
happening for given image while for
second one it is not you basically
prepare that and you train a triplate
loss so you for a given original sample
you have anchor and you have positives
and negatives which are the information
leakage happening and for one not
happening so those are the pairs and
then you basically train that the anchor
positive and negative and you train the
triplet loss the model is trained let's
say now in the test time what you do is
that you push this two corresponding
images original and reconstructed and
you produce a feature vector and you get
a similar for two feature vectors you
can produce a given score right our
generated scores relates very well to
the human observers standpoint that if
our metric says that you know these two
things are not similar it relates very
well what human agreed with if it says
is that you know the score is very less
then the human it aligns again very well
with the human Observer standpoint and
that's what we are showing in that space
when we say that we also compared with
psnr MSE and other metrics from a
structure similarity or trainable meth
methods as well our method consistently
performs well in addition if you see an
interesting thing here is that for a
given data set if you pick up a FID for
example it is not necessary that the
same metric performs well for the other
method for every every other data set
some other metric performs well that
requires even more importance or more
need that you pick up one metric that is
universal in nature and that's what we
say show that it consistently performs
well just not for inversion gradients
method but you could also use different
attack methods here and it's the same
for any attack method or different data
set is consistently performs well
additionally if you consider setup where
you use for your model training you
could use different type of met method
or different networks as a backbone it
again performs consistently well
together with if you change from triplet
loss to quive loss it again performs
well and the results improve
consistently if you increase the
training number of samples and further
we also show one another use case is
that if you do not do the training and
if you just try to do a retrieval the
retrieval tends to say or the the scores
somehow for similar dissimilar they tend
to have no order and that's why they all
are like all over but in our set of
given our train method once you have
trained it then the most similar ones
and the most dissimilar ones get further
away that clearly shows that the more
information leakage is happening here
and less information leakage is
happening As you move across the line
and that's more or less the paper and
additionally one thing that we have done
in our paper in our setup we had binary
setup where you lose information or or
you don't lose information but this
could be done over a scale from 1
through 10 a lot of information leakage
is happening over a scale that is
something that we still want to work on
in our next
papers that's overall the paper thanks
excellent so is the do you you publish
the data set here yeah we do okay the
paper the yes the data set is uh already
accessible yeah additionally with the
labels and I think that we will also
share all the codes and all the
necessary things that we have shown here
very cool yeah that's the plan awesome
thank you very much so
[Music]
much